[Music] I have a
group coming.
We always go on safari here in the
Red Sea. We rent a boat called Bloom from a company
called
[Music].
Every morning we wake up on it at dawn every day. We wake up at 6:00 in the morning and the pre
-dive is at six and a half and we are
with one of the guys.  He saw the royal smoke linking
us with the center between us and him, about fifty meters. The
young man said in light smoke, and within maybe a
minute or two, we found that the smoke
became heavy white, then
it became black. [Music] And the fire started, meaning more and very quickly, because the authorities were in a little bit of air. We ordered them to untie the
ropes first thing, so that when  He comes to us and
does not acknowledge our insiders. They helped the second place
among the people and brought them down to us
[music] in the
Navy. To be honest, they did not fail. I mean, there were
light wounds. They gave them a bandage, which we gave them water, and
all this talk, and then that's it, and it's okay and it's from the
dispatcher. I mean, always in first aid matters, there
's someone in chief, and that's it, we'll go away.  A little bit
[music]